we will give you a throwback clip old
school
former prime minister of England
Margaret Thatcher summarizing who the
enemy actually is
the essence of socialism is that you
surrender quite a bit of power over your
own life to the state where we all do
that to some extent but of course it
went much further
you pay very high taxes and they wish to
take even higher taxes because they
think that politicians can spend money
better than the people can spend it the
more you take away the less there is for
Private Industry and that's where the
creation of wealth comes so you have to
establish very clear limits on the role
of government and really you know
politicians I think should sometimes
just be a little bit more modest about
their abilities than they are we can't
run everything and we shouldn't try
as a bachelor though you're going for
Attitudes you're trying to change the
way people think about their role in
life it's almost sometimes as though you
think by your own resolve you can
somehow inspire people to be different
you're still inside if I could suggest a
little of that very bright green
Grocer's daughter who made herself a
chemist made herself a tax lawyer made
herself prime minister anybody can
I don't really quite recognize what
you're saying I believe certain things
very strongly
I believe that we were going towards a
way of life in which people were
constantly looking to the state to solve
their problems and to do things for them
you know when the state does everything
for you it'll soon take everything from
you
you will then have no basis for personal
freedom
political freedom
nor economic freedom I saw it going much
too far and I think it would have gone
even further had I not won that 1979
election too far ever to pull it back
it's brilliant it's true and it's
actually quite chilling as Joe
Scarborough
calls the people who fight the collusion
between government and corporations
fascists
that's the truth right there that's the
truth the more that you ask for the
government the more that you demand the
government do for you the more that you
become a slave to that government the
more you become a slave to the machine
we have a couple people right now in
this country who are trying to fight
that and we have a whole corporate press
and a big Tech monstrosity and a bunch
more that are trying to destroy those
people whether they're Donald Trump or
their Ron DeSantis regardless of who you
happen to like more at the moment and
there's other people as well and the
challenge is
for you to figure out how you can fight
alongside of them that was a Margaret
Thatcher impersonation by the way Brock
announced in the middle of that clip
that until three months ago he thought
that Margaret Thatcher was actually a
member of The Golden Girls so it's all
very confusing around here
[Music]